Speaker 1: So scam financial scam story number
one is Trump said he would be donating his
presidential salary.
Washington Post can find no evidence that
the last six months of his salary were actually
donated.
The next piece of the financial scam is that
it is now believed Donald Trump moved donated
money, money donated to fight the unfair election
results to his own businesses, according to
new filings.
Check out this article by Greg Grazioso, which
says Donald Trump moved more than 200.
That, I guess, is supposed to be two hundred
thousand twenty thousand two hundred thousand
dollars donated to his Make America Great
Again PAC into his own private business accounts,
according to an analysis of his federal filings.
The money was moved in February, a month after
Trump left office.
Money donated to PACs is meant to be spent
solely on campaign efforts.
Forbes reports that the former president also
set up a leadership PAC generally used to
support other candidates.
That's the PAC where he said, I will tell
you who the good Republicans are.
Donate to me and I'll distribute the money
as I see fit.
Trump took 30 million dollars from his Make
America Great Again PAC and moved it to the
new PAC called Save America.
That PAC eventually grew to 90 million dollars
and Trump took an additional seventy nine
thousand dollars out of that PAC for his own
uses.
Trump's business, the Trump org regularly
interacted with his campaign PACs.
In one instance, the Trump charged his campaign
PAC thirty eight thousand to rent in rent
via Trump Tower Commercial LLC, of which Trump
is 100 percent owner.
During 2016, Trump ran his campaign out of
the skyscraper, but his 2012 campaign was
partially run from DC.
Despite this, the Trump organization continued
to collect rent for Trump Tower.
In total, the Trump organization collected
one hundred and eighty eight thousand in rent
between January and June, all paid through
Trump's campaign donations.
Trump restaurants also collected rent from
the PAC, even after the former president left
office and during a time when tourist visiting
Trump Tower were few due to the coronavirus
pandemic totaling fifteen thousand dollars.
And it just goes on and on.
Save America, the leadership PAC paid Trump
Hotel collection seventy nine thousand after
Trump was out of office expenses largely for
lodging and meals.
The Trump Organization did not comment on
the self dealing payments, but the former
president did issue a statement boasting that
his affiliated committees have approximately
one hundred million dollars of cash ready
for use.
The statement said these fundraising numbers,
coupled with tremendous support in so many
other ways, show that President Trump's supporters
want him to continue to fight.
We we knew that the pack save America pack,
we we knew the entire donate so that we can
fight the election results, we told you it
was a grift back in December, January, February.
If you looked at the fine print when they
were sending out the fundraising emails, it
would say we can use up to up to 50 cents
of every dollar donated to pay off campaign
debts, for example.
This is really it's almost like a political
version of the producers.
And I still go back to the idea that Trump's
entire 2016 primary run was really just a
way to make money and get publicity and become
more more well known and then monetize it
after losing the Republican primary or certainly
after losing the election.
But Trump overestimated, apparently, the intelligence
of his own electorate of the Republican Party
electorate.
And when you do that, weird things can happen.
And the weird thing that happened was that
the Republican electorate was actually ignorant
enough and radical enough to vote Trump to
be their nominee.
And his followers still to this day believe
he was draining the swamp or whatever it was.
So, again, it's just like with Trump salary,
this amount of money should really be meaningless
to Trump like 79 grand into the Trump Tower
restaurants and 20 grand or a hundred grand
or one hundred and eighty eight in.
These are amounts of money that should be
meaningless to a guy like Trump, who, even
by the conservative estimates, has to pay
two billion dollars.
But this it's greedy, cheap and narcissistic.
And what will his followers say?
Probably nothing.
That's the reality.
If you won't go to his followers, they will
say, listen to this.
This is a guy with why would he go to some
crappy restaurant when he has his own restaurants
where he can hold campaign events?
Why would he get some office when he owns
so much real estate?
It makes sense that he would do this.
They will defend him to the last day.
It was a grift from day one and the financial
documents seem to support it.
Will there be consequences for self dealing?
Probably not.
But it is certainly the type of thing where
if it were Democrats doing this, it would
be 24/7 on Fox News.
It's not even a story on right wing media,
though.